what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU and of course the
Spider-Man universe over at Sony and
right now it's actually sounding like
Sony does indeed have a good plan for
their Spider-Man universe if you've been
following the channel or just keeping up
with Spider-Man news in general lately
you probably know that Sony seemingly
has some plans up their sleeves not just
for Spider-Man but for their entire
Spider-Man universe and as I've
mentioned before it does seem like Sony
is building up to a really really big
event possibly spider get in this will
essentially be Avengers end game and
Avengers Secret Wars just in the Sony
Universe specifically focused on
Spider-Man but many many different
variants of Spider-Man and I really mean
that I'm talking about a lot of
different variants of Spider-Man some
obscure ones some amazing ones some new
ones I'm sure are going to be introduced
on screen that might not be characters
in the comics and the best part is is it
does seem like this is an opportunity
for Sony to make a lot of movies that we
are really really excited about and also
give opportunities that we are really
excited about as well such as Toby
Maguire Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man returning on screen yet again
Spider-Man no way home brought the three
Spider-Man together it was amazing and
of course we all loved it however what
if that was just the start for Sony in
this video I want to talk about Sony's
plan and how I think their spiderverse
is about to be insanely huge and also of
course talk about what movies and what
Spider-Man we can expect to see in the
upcoming future of the Sony Universe
because I for one am really excited with
where I think Sony is going even though
we might have to see some Spider-Man
variants actually die on screen and
don't worry I don't think it's going to
be Tom Holland Spider-Man or Andrew
Garfield's or Toby Maguire's now at this
point we all know that the biggest
Spider-Man success stories for for Sony
are Spider-Man homecoming far from home
and of course no way home and Spider-Man
into the spider-verse and of course
Venom and with the exception of the
Venom franchise Spider-Man no way home
and Spider-Man into the spider-verse put
on screen multiple variants of
Spider-Man and Sony has realized that
this works for them and fans love to see
it well as it turns out it looks like
they're rolling with that and they're
basing their whole entire new universe
off of the spider-verse which is a
really really great idea and they're
kicking this off with Madame Webb now if
you don't know much about Madame Webb
for the comics basically all you need to
know for Sony's purposes is that in the
comics Madame Webb can travel through
the Multiverse she is essentially a
cosmic being and she has the power to
travel through different universes and
this is the movie that we are getting
February 16th of 2024 about a year and a
half away a little less and this movie
is really where we are about to see the
spider-verse come into play and if
you're wondering what type of spider
versions going to introduce we are
talking a lot of different Spider-Man
variants if you've seen into the
spider-verse we're pretty much talking
about that only more also recently as
far as across the spider-verse is
concerned which is into the spider-verse
2. The Insider account can we get some
toast recently tweeted this morning
seriously across the spider-verse is
going to be so effing cool we're gonna
have so many different spider characters
it's insane I'm excited for spider cat
and I'm really excited for spider cat as
well and this is just an example of what
Sony is starting to do Implement new
Spider-Man characters into their
universes now of course across the
spider-verse is going to be an animated
film but with the Multiverse coming into
play for Sony Spider-Man universe I
believe that the Animated Universe is
going to cross over into the live-action
Universe eventually not just yet you see
Sony did originally have a plan and many
people know parts of this plan it was
kind of Muddy wasn't very well put
together and it quite often changed
recently very much for the better their
original plan was to have some
characters from the MCU Spider-Man
universe jump over to their Universe
their plan was to use Tom Holland
Spider-Man as the main Spider-Man in
their universe and eventually do
crossovers with Venom morbius
essentially do a Sinister Six film
however a few things have changed and
most of that came with the success of
Spider-Man Noe home and the failure of
morbius not to mention the very
confusing post-credits scene however
since then they have kind of shifted
from doing this sort of sinister six
idea which isn't completely off the
table by the way it should happen
eventually but they've shifted from that
mentality to a Multiverse of Spider-Man
mentality a spider-verse which is a much
better plan and to top it all off they
are Consulting with Kevin feige for each
project they do concerning Spider-Man
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and Kevin
foggy have been a large part of the
success of Tom Holland Spider-Man
because he is in in the MCU and because
Kevin feige Had Creative control luckily
for us Sony has realized this that Kevin
foggy is someone of a genius and he has
good direction and it has been revealed
that Kevin feige does work with them on
each Spider-Man project now so there's a
lot more Synergy now between Sony and
Disney slash Marvel Studios which is
perfect because Sony is trying to do a
spider verse and Kevin feige created the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and now Sony
seemingly has a pretty good plan we'll
get to that in just a bit but first big
thank you to Mint mobile for sponsoring
this video most people know about mint
mobile because of Ryan Reynolds but most
people don't know about mint Mobile's
amazing quality and I have to say
there's an extremely good reason that
Ryan Reynolds is pushing mint mobile so
much because it actually is a great
phone company mint mobile sent me a free
plan and at first I didn't think too
much of it I have one of the major
Wireless providers however I don't get
that good of service with my provider
and over the past three months I've
gotten incredible service with mint
mobile to the point to where if I
actually need to make a phone call I
will use my mint mobile phone and what's
crazy is their plan is so much cheaper
mint mobile offers Wireless for just 15
bucks a month they give you the best
rate whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint mobile families start
at only two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network plus mint Mobile's Modern
Family Plan lets you mix and match data
plan so everyone gets the amount of data
that's right for them and you you can
use your own phone and keep your same
number and contacts so to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
including the Modern Family Plan go to
mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
build down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic so Sony's plan is
kind of cool it's actually really cool
based off of what we've heard from some
insiders Sony is going to have a main
spider-verse villain not just a villain
for one film but for the spider-verse in
general which is a really cool concept
to think about if this is true this
could work really well and there are
signs that this is indeed true some set
photos from Madame Webb have revealed a
character that is seemingly dressed up
in a Spider-Man outfit well according to
some insiders this is actually going to
be Ezekiel Sims and this very well could
be our main big bad multiversal villain
According to some insiders he is going
to be going around in different
universes killing off different
Spider-Man kind of like the Terminator
but in the Multiverse now at this point
in time we're not really sure if the
whole spider totem story is going to be
adapted in Sony spiderverse but if they
are going to go that way which they very
well could because of Madame Webb that's
going to be awesome essentially we'll
have spider gods in the Spider-Man
universe who can select avatars in which
a couple of Peter Parkers have been
avatars before for them but as of right
now what the Insiders are saying is that
Ezekiel Sims is probably the villain who
is going through the Multiverse hunting
down different Spider-Man or
Spider-Woman because of course there are
female variants of Spider-Man and that's
kind of the whole point Sony's
spider-verse is now going to bring
everyone together spider Gwen Spider
Woman Miles Morales Spider-Man 2099 and
hopefully lead up to spider get in which
is essentially all of the different
variants from the other universes coming
to the main Universe to stop a threat
now what is that ultimate threat going
to be we're not sure right now that
could be Ezekiel Sims but I'm thinking
they probably have a bigger villain in
mind because there's always a bigger
fish or they could have multiple
villains which is why they need so many
different variants of Spider-Man to all
come together in one Universe now if
this is truly the way that the Sony
spider versus going this is huge it's
epic this could be incredible and could
completely turn around the spider-verse
for Sony because within this universe
you could still do The Amazing
Spider-Man 3. you could do another movie
with Toby Maguire you could do spider
Gwen you could do spider Punk who we
know is coming in across the
spider-verse the great thing about this
is that the potential is Limitless we
can get our movie with Tom Hardy's Venom
going up against Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man we could get a Sinister Six
film within this universe but still have
a big bad and a bigger multiversal story
happening the only thing that I sadly
would not expect is Tom Holland
Spider-Man to have a major role in this
universe could he appear in some films
sure but I think in order to not confuse
people Marvel Studios is going to want
Tom Holland Spider-Man to to pretty much
sit on the sidelines for Sony
spider-verse and just stay in the MCU
mostly especially with Secret Wars
coming up but again if this is Sony's
true plan for the spider-verse they
don't necessarily need Tom Holland
Spider-Man would it be cool of course
would it be necessary no and I truly
hope that everything we've heard is true
and it does seemingly look like that
especially from what we've seen from the
set photos for Madame Webb so if this is
Sony's plan I'm really really excited
for the future of not just one
Spider-Man but a lot of different
variants of Spider-Man and this is
definitely a better route for Sony to go
100 but hey let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below do
you like this plan or do you not please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest Spider-Man news for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf